Hello Freak bitches.
It's um,
it all is about the,
the,
uh,
the issues with interspecies
communication.
Let's pray.
Dolphins,
they kind of understand the concept,
but they can't make the noise cause they
have a blowhole.
But this lady was trying,
she was living with this thing for a
long time and she was jerking the
dolphin off and then they would,
they,
I still train that and lily was doing
acid and try it and they cut off funding
or,
you know,
it's like I respect that,
the,
the effort,
but at the same time or how does she do
that?
Right.
And however you get another dolphin,
you know,
maybe you just have to,
you don't have to live with the golf and
the game and there's gotta be a better
way.
I think they were of in that dolphin was
the fucking happy.
I can't imagine.
It was like,
this is great.
I'm living with a lady.
I don't know if he thought it was bad.
I mean,
we have this big hang up about
sexuality.
But imagine if you had an itch on your
back and you couldn't reach it and you
know you were being taken care of by
someone and they scratched your back
before you,
you're like,
oh thank you.
I just mean I would always lean towards
like fun,
put the dog that,
I mean I'm,
I'm more of a don't jerk and animal off
kind of a guy,
but I just mean there's,
my point is well then maybe get a better
facility to keep the Dolphin and get a
couple of dolphins,
let them live,
put them in a,
I don't know.
I mean you know anytime you have an
animal in captivity it's pretty fucked
up.
But I don't know that jerking him off is
the right way to do it.
She's totally run.
Would you do,
which was if you had to choose an animal
that jerk off,
which is not a,
you know,
a lot of people ask me this question.
I would not do it at the monkey cause if
you do it wrong then bite you.
I think deal with a monkey would be a
little bit too much,
like just doing it with a dude rough and
he was like an off a monkey and they
just fucking sunk their teeth of your
thumb.
I don't like ball exotic.
I'd go like giraffe because it's tall.
You could stand,
you know,
but they might come and kick you in the
head.
They might look,
there's always a risk.
There's always a risk.
When he was checking in producer the
daily show,
no one said it was
dyed jerking off a donkey.
But I think it's a terrible way to go
cause they're so cute.
Do you know the rape a lot?
Yeah.
Really little bears are famous for
raping each other.
Well,
there you go.
A vicious,
they when they fuck they bite and really
fucking get crazy.
I did not know that.
Yeah,
you don't want to jerk off.
That's what I'm saying.
Don't bite you.
Bite the shit.
I wouldn't need to sleep on this.
I'll let you guys know.
Yeah,
let's,
uh,
let's put this to a test.
I mean,
what she did was ridiculous but only
ridiculous by our cultural standards.
If you think about it like biologically,
the real issue biologically is,
you're right.
Like you shouldn't have a dolphin and
captivity like that.
That's all.
But in the,
uh,
the podcasts,
they started document why they did it
because it was,
it's really hard to communicate with
dolphins in the wild.
Yeah.
I did this thing in Hawaii recently
where we went swimming with the
dolphins.
I had my four year old with me too,
and she was in the water like right next
to me.
I literally,
I was holding onto her while we were
swimming and she's got the scuba mask on
and shit and she's,
you know,
snorkeling,
looking down while it's often swim
underneath it.
It's amazing.
And they're wild.
These are not like sea world and
they'll,
they'll sonar you like
it's fucking cool.
Get near you or they'll make like weird
noises and shit.
I like that.
The lady,
every time I talked to Carter to Maya
calculations,
he's saying jerk me off.
I've just listened to him.
I mean,
we don't know that for sure.
Trust me.
I speak to off and he wants to be jerked
off.
It's like seeing that woman went jogging
and Florida and she was,
you know,
it was like seven that night and she had
a long day at work.
She went right and she just dangled a
feed off the bridge.
I just got to dangle my feet.
I'm just fucking hot and an 11 foot
alligator was like,
I'm going to,
I'll take you now.
I'll be having you now.
Don't,
Oh,
you found it with no arms.
Took her arms.
Fuck yeah,
that's good.
Alligator was like,
I know I'm an alligator and usually I
don't do this cause the crocodiles do
it.
I'm going to do it today to you.
You're going to be the only three people
or four people of the year that's going
to be eaten by a fucking 11 foot dragon.
That'll be me.
You the weird that alligators,
they let them hang around because
they're not too aggressive.
It's like they're just docile and he
usually run from you that people don't
just decide to fucking kill them on
site,
but really everyone in Florida should be
in up in arms.
They should run out to the swamps and
gun those fucking dinosaurs down.
Like those are a bunch of kid eating dog
eating monster shit out of dogs and a
guy was walking his dog and they all get
it.
Didn't go for the dog when for the guy
just fucking Jesus.
Yeah,
they're just not as aggressive as crocs.
If they were crocs,
we would be killing them.
Leftlane right.
Crocodiles,
they found nial crocs in the everglades.
Stop it.
Yes they have.
There's a shoot on sight order.
I fucked dial crocodile people hadn't
used to have them as pets.
Nile crocodiles,
they don't know if they're breeding.
They don't.
Don't have any idea what their spot in
more than one Nile crocodile in the
everglades confirmed sightings.
They're saying straight up killers.
Yep.
You see them,
they kill them onsite.
Straight up come.
They will come right at you.
You are food as a here and there being
big.
Oh,
they get really bad.
Like that peace corps girl who was like,
oh,
they were in Kenya.
Well,
the crocodiles died out years ago.
She heard,
she heard,
she goes swimming.
The guy's like,
I don't know.
She's like,
I'm going in with the radio.
I'm a water baby.
30 seconds later I'll get to pull it on
her house.
Got My feet too.
There was a document or an article I was
reading about these people that were
canoeing in the Congo and the guy behind
washes,
the guy in front gets taken by the crock
with a Croc,
just rises up out of the water and
literally snatches the guy and spins the
canoe upside kayak rather.
Oh the sky.
And stuck in it and it like goes up and
down like a bobber and then pump and
then pops up.
No Guy.
That's it.
He doesn't see the guy over again.
The CROC just takes them out of the
water.
Yeah.
And just so the model of that story is
don't fucking Kayak in denial.
I mean in,
in the Congo,
you don't do that.
That would be the motto of that story.
Oh fucking are you out of your fucking
mind?
They're not like sharks.
They will bother you.
They come after you come after
everything.
That's what they're,
they're here for cleaning up.
I'll just sit in Uganda.
He saw,
saw what a craig,
I'll eat a god damn tire.
Eat a whole time.
It's like,
I'm going to heat this tire.
Oh,
fucking tired.
I was like,
can you repeat that again?
He goes,
it ain't a tyro cartera cause yet eight.
Oh my God.
So your your food.
Yeah.